we'll try not to complain about the
construction Jim Gaffigan is here I will
absolutely complain about the
construction if I hear I know every
single person by the way he's come in
Travis's like yeah my wife heard it in
headphones this person heard it that
person heard it somebody called in and
said it shook their entire car yeah
Kevin was saying that no one could hear
it but apparently I'm looking here we
have construction going on so it's very
distracting yeah and I don't want to be
embarrassed in front of our guests Jim
Gaffigan you know I was very impressed
with the show until I notice the
construction and there wasn't even a
sign that said pardon our dust we care
so much about yeah right it's
interesting I had no idea that serious
had turned into LaGuardia no it was part
of LaGuardia and it's weird I had to
park like three blocks away yeah yeah
you've flown in LaGuardia in last
it's a nightmare nightmare yeah it's
really out of control
although then there was that story I
mean JFK I guess is not that much better
cuz there's that story like over the
weekend or something there's poor people
were trying to fly to Miami and they
were stuck on the JFK tarmac for eight
hours just sitting on a plane and that's
their fault goes to Miami during this
summer
no but that's Brooke it's avoidable why
should airlines be able to like leave
you out there for eight hours what is
there a rule that they couldn't it was
like my three hour maximum and then they
had to like I'll let you give the
optional leaving then they're like
brawls happening and you know the the
airplane police have to come out and say
let's stay calm like no we didn't let
people stand out right sit down we're
gonna just stand here and tell the
person in six for six F sets down just a
guy in the bathroom that wouldn't get
out you have to sure we can't leave if
you're in the bathroom david chung tells
a story like that where he was like
there was like a line and he had to go
and pass it he went to piss and they're
like sit down we're gonna lose our place
in LA like in the take-off line and i
think either he caused them to miss
their place in the take-off line where
he had to come back and they had to like
kind of go back and around because he
[ __ ] up and just you know yup
nobody terrible story it's yeah I
apologize david terribly does it know
there's a terrible story no it was a
joke story it was a ruin the vibe story
I gotcha apologize you every time they
have those stories where you know uh
holiday travel this is gonna be really
really bad and there's delays and this
person is on Stryker or you hear stories
about people waiting on the tarmac or
these horrible like LaGuardia stories
probably not a popular option with the
airline companies but why wouldn't
everybody just say okay there has to be
less flights like they're just camp
there's two that's the issue there's too
many planes trying to take off all at
the same time right yeah and they're
also they're packed right yeah I mean I
travel I remember when there used to be
empty flights and now it's just we're
overbooked you know and like no one do
you have a bag or you know like if
you're overweight you have to check your
stomach after binge and purge cancel
flights they cancel morning flights that
aren't sold out all the timely the sale
you know this flights been canceled we
bumped you back to our and you know it's
just because their flight wasn't sold
okay we you know there's not enough
people on this plane to don't you fly
private or no do you ever fly I have I
have once when I was doing a charity
event no I
yeah I've the privates the way to go
it's gotta be I mean I don't remember
end up complaining about that do you
yeah and then you're like all these gold
bricks why can't they make them lighter
you know I flew on Jeffrey Epstein's no
to Lolita Express doesn't have good food
is it funny hat Jeffrey Epstein yeah I
find a below little there's stories keep
coming out yeah you know there's party
it's such a horrifying thing but you're
like how long do we have to wait like
are we waiting for season two of Jeffrey
Epstein to find out who was on the list
right like well they release it even
when you're reading stories that are the
headline is one time Jeffrey Epstein got
two teenage French girls for his
birthday three three three you're going
like this is becoming a parody of itself
who's on the list yeah yeah woman knows
that you know there's a thing that one
of the girls said that she took the
woman taught her how to
oral sex I don't know how old she was
but that woman knows I had been wouldn't
we know by now you would think so you'd
think if it in my head it's just a list
right like it's not that secret or
hidden like there's blue went we're like
we're in the middle of a conspiracy
theory right where are they just gonna
drag it out and and then people are like
alright we'll move on to something else
yeah you know alright Greenland I feel
like somebody's sunk somebody's gonna
get sunk if somebody big Prince Andrew
I don't think Clinton butts gonna be
somebody like that and then people's
appetite what kind of like alright we
got one there's somebody huge that went
down because there's just too many big
people kind of circling is Dershowitz
like by the way we're just gonna like
here's the thing go after one of the
most brilliant lawyers of modern time
yeah it's like libel through it
allegedly there was an implied question
mark at the end but it's just I don't
know man there's a level of like you
know where I mean I I sincerely feel
like we're you know like we all of those
friends they're like totally in
conspiracy theories and I'm like this is
we're living through one definitely
right definitely the high the whole
pedophile ring it makes it like wow Alex
Jones was not as crazy when you hear
like all these all these rich pedophiles
and all these no you look at what's
happening it's a God Christ there is a
ring yeah yeah there are high-profile
pedophiles yeah and and it's like they
work together and this one knows about
that one and he'll bring girls in for
it's a it's not as crazy as I thought it
you can't believe it happens sometimes
no it's just insane but can you imagine
if you're Dershowitz I mean you have to
on some level feel so accomplished to
know that not only did you basically
help get Jeffrey Epstein off the first
time you know he did like whatever he
did 13 months hours a day he was out he
pretty much got him off he also helped
get okay off right Oh Jay and Epstein
well he also got there was the lady
Helmsley you got ya Helmsley yeah what
did she she was frozen it wasn't a tax
evasion or something because she used
money fun she murdered her husband
I assume the rich the bad wait did she
murder her husband did I literally just
give a tax charge to a woman who comes
there with some spouse that died let's
see what it is like after allegations of
non-payment were made by contractors
hired to improve her Connecticut home
she was investigating taxes convicted on
federally put a murderer that's like
murder it's like murder it's similar
it's the same connection I got to pay my
fair share you know I mean you're
killing me here
yeah she was really hated I think of her
every time I Drive because the Helmsley
building is in the middle of Park Avenue
so you kind of drive under it right I
think of that rotten old lady you do
she was a great kisser she could be so
romantic
yeah she was are all dollars and cents
she was she would just sit back and chat
that's really nice just got to know each
other hey do you still work the common
ship I haven't been there in a while I
learned recently I guess that's where we
met and doing late night at the strip
and I went there recently to do a pocket
it looks different now it looks like you
have to look apparently before I got
into the business
it's so insane and that was like a
hundred years ago like it's just insane
how long it's been like I'll run into
people I'm like I met you 30 years ago
I'm like wait a minute mine my dad yeah
I mean like the context of talking of
things of like 20 years ago in 30 years
ago is absurd you look at the headshots
on the wall and I'm like out of the
business dead really famous really
famous dead out of the biz it's amazing
how many people are dead or just left or
that I'm like who the [ __ ] is that right
right and then you're like oh it's me
yeah never sure it did it no I never
made it to the comic strip wall oh I
don't think so
that's a bummer sure you're up there no
I might have at one point maybe over it
like in the corner at one point make at
this point you'd be up there no well
that's it's more about them than it does
about yeah really what's that all about
everyone we should kind of like protest
by not go
there yet cancel comics trap I had a
douchey headshot thought I had one mine
and my hands around my hips and iron
shirt under I was really remember though
I was awful
there was no good headshots though right
were there no but there was levels of
awful and I really liked well I think
Jim and Reno's had a head shot where he
had just two q-tips coming out of his
ears I remember that that was up at the
comic strip well-liked young headshots
are so bad because you can feel the
desperation trying to be funny yeah like
you can feel I'm trying to get
everything out so the casting director
will see in this road oh how much I
could do and you go ah and it doesn't
work never the 90s were bad too they had
these weird little like like almost like
a frame was like a whiteboard order yeah
and this end this weird kind of like
weird frame around it on the inside
there was were terrible heads and it was
before by the way you had to pay a lot
like that was something you'd you'd save
up your I'm gonna get headshots yeah I
can't make it here yeah I'm working
until I can afford new headshots we have
to pay for a Taser guy named Peter clues
when these go to Caroline and tape
everybody and you [ __ ] you know you'd
spend whatever it cost to get him in
there and he was great but you know you
just googled yourself and printed out
yeah and then you'd go and go to his
place and he kind of like live like the
Unabomber somewhere on the Upper West
Side and you'd visit him and he was you
know I remember just being the
struggling comedian I'm like any advice
you can give me and he gave me advice
was invited I think he advised reading a
book thank you so much hey have you gone
to Rome Rome yeah yeah so when you go
you perform for the Pope when you when
you go is somewhere like that do you try
to see him again
no like are we friends after like yeah
like he might remember me hey Pope when
I was introduced to him like the guy was
like behind him speaking in Italian or
Spanish like comedic duh americano you
know I mean so like now he wouldn't
write when you're performing you
performed former you just met him I
performed before
or he came in like literally on the same
stage as the poets so when is that gig a
super-high pressure gig or you just
thinking yourself too much stuff it's a
no-win situation it seems like you know
two million people outside in
Philadelphia
and none of them were there to see stand
up there to see the Pope no one's going
I hope there's a complain about like
having to open for bands the gaff again
is there like yeah one time I did
someone's probably gonna open for Putin
you know yeah I'm doing a show in Moscow
are you I am in November that's gonna be
that's gonna be interesting now do you
have you gotten a lot of contact from
Moscow like fans and try this I I wanted
to do I mean I love doing international
shows so I was like I'm doing the Baltic
and Baltic states and I knew a guy this
promoter in Asia and I was like and he
came through he's like hey I can get
your show in Moscow which is crazy right
I mean I don't know if you know how many
people there cuz English is not like
write something people pick up there
right yeah I was gonna ask you like when
you're doing a show like that that's not
only international but a totally
different culture yeah do you start
researching the culture to kind of
figure out what's gonna work what's not
gonna work maybe it's a little bit like
you know when people when comedians come
from other parts of the country and
they're doing spots in New York they're
like this Subway's crazy like first low
hanging fruit kind of thing right
hopefully your point of view is unique
but I don't know
and we'll see you know and you know like
I don't know like with Netflix and like
because you have specials on HBO two and
one and HBO yeah like what is the the
biggest reach like from a foreign
country has it been HBO or is it been
Netflix I would say it's gotta be
Netflix a lot of its from radio online
stuff to do like how the people of
YouTube you yeah radio bits but I always
say up the to Netflix definitely just
because HBO is
more regional I mean I'm sure it's
available there but Netflix they all
kind of and they put their comedy stuff
front and center oh yeah and they get it
all at the same time so I would say I
did I did England I did five five
European cities and I did English and it
was all they all like new me from
Netflix oh that's amazing
what made you decide to not do your
special on Netflix
well I some of it is I think the
business of specials is changing
constantly like I my first special was
on Comedy Central and it ended up like
in 2006 when I was twelve thousand six
what and that was like perfect timing
where every dorm room had Comedy Central
on right every what you can now like no
no college kid has cable right and so it
shifts every five years I mean granted
they they approached me but I mean I get
like three boxes from Amazon a day and
they offered me half the company of
Amazon Wow divorce it's like so I can't
Gaffigan half in the ex-wife terrible so
you know and I every day I talked to the
bays you know hey you know instead of
the smiley curved arrow on the box how
about my mug and he's like yeah let's do
it so they aren't gonna change that oh
that's huge
oh it's on Amazon Prime so how do you
look at it can they stream in yeah if
you get packages delivered which is most
people then you probably have Prime and
then if you don't have Prime I think
there's like a one-month free trial okay
Emma's on Primus is amazing because
people got it at first just because it
gave you you pay whatever you pay and
they give you two days shipping on
everything yeah yeah and so that's
that's like there's a tremendous value
in that sure yeah and then one day they
just decided what if we also gave you
just a ton of content ah yeah and you go
yeah I would accept that yeah I would
accept more content yeah
can I still have the two day shipping
and
yeah that sounds that's good it is it's
fascinating to consider that like that
the place that we order socks and paper
towels is also like providing content
yeah that's absurd yeah you can go to
Amazon yeah I just got a 24 pack of Z
via that soda made with stevia yes and
that's the same place where we'll get
your special so that's also you probably
causing cancer you think so it's like
listening I'm really hoping it doesn't
cost Kenny one of the only healthy
things I do really it's not yeah it's
not artificial it's a fake sugar alters
it's natural it's a natural sugar that's
why I because I was natural cancer
cancer is natural I know you're right
about that there's nothing more natural
than weed weed okay to you what's that
and we do you know partake in weed but
you partake I've gone through periods
where I'm like not doing anything you
know look I used to work out a lot I you
know like now you're thin and I'm fat
but when you were first your sake you
big do like a wrestler you arrest my
ability but it's just like the jackets
don't fit anymore and I'm like I
literally have to wear a jacket cuz if I
don't wear a jacket from the side I look
like a moving van it's just way too big
like but do you look at that and go like
okay I got to do something or do you go
you know what there's a guys enjoying
his life I just you know I also there's
too many aches and pains
mm-hmm like I wake up and I'm like I
don't know but like do you have joint
pain or anything yeah my knee my left
name I have it sure I don't know why I
tell people like no one cares what I
look like or you look male comics right
right what I think this is my fat like I
can feel like like will you turn a
certain way you feel the side roll and
you're like I'm such a fat and nobody
cares like people are looking at that
give no they don't care but I think
because I am fat that my joints hurt cuz
I'm like to the lecture wounds
cariann well I was the guy sitting on my
on my couch hacking the election the
Trump was talking about I was hacking
the election and then I got in the
business with the Bayes column the Bayes
have you met him or no I've met him yeah
I mean you know yeah the weird thing
about like Amazon is I'm sure they're
making more money off of socks then any
entertainment form yes one more thing
it's one more thing someone's like
Netflix is overspending just to wipe
everybody else out and that's what
they're doing Amazon makes all their
money selling server space yeah they do
like it's all the stuff that isn't sort
of I mean it's known but it's not the
commercial stuff it's like they the CIA
buy his server space from an from Amazon
Wow yeah I know that when I sold my
special through my website the useful
Amazon was behind it do you like said
you like doing your own through your
website I mean Louis did a great job
with that yeah Aziz did it I mean
there's a certain level of guys that can
do it
I think it's you know but that was a
time you know now I don't know if it
would work I just think it's like
getting people to go to your website
yeah like that used to happen but now
it's like yes he's back on Netflix yeah
yeah it's one of those things now you're
right where maybe the transition has
become that everybody's got their
streaming service whatever it is right
in front of them you know so it's like
you know they hear you talking about it
but they're not gonna go search for
anything because anytime you turn on
Netflix or Amazon Prime or whatever it
is yeah whatever the thing is that's
right in front of you
you're like new thing like HBO
we're so predisposed to like some of
those shows that it's it's it's a
conspiracy I get lazy though and you
would have run a funny job which I've
thought of again a thousand times about
when you're reading a newspaper and they
say continued on page four not for me
it's like if it's not right in front of
me or if I go to an article and it's
like hey subscribe nope I don't
really important article you like I
really need to know and they're like
sign up for The Wall Street Journal
you're like no thanks no and then about
spending a dollar 75 on this I'm gonna
Ford a dollar to support journalism and
in the moment you're super invested and
super interested whatever the topic is
and then the minute you decide I'm not
doing that and you move on to the next
thing you forget you ever forget and
that's how people are with us though
it's like yeah if it's not like it right
in front of you people like yeah I'd
love to see that but a week later it's
amazing yeah and you stopped doing your
show we were talking about this off the
air and that was was that because of the
family or did you was it too
time-consuming and you don't want to do
it it was it was really time consuming
but it was also it was me and my wife
and so like we were and we have five
kids so was ridiculous like I had to
kind of convince her because it was kind
of a dream situation yeah but a funny
show like yeah really good show but it
was just it was too you know it's like
you're kind of managing how much you
want to do constantly right and so I'm
like I don't know if I wanted in it took
14 hours a day and there's certain
people like when Louie did his
innumerable shows it's like I look at
that and I'm like that's too much that's
way too much yeah he would also do an
hour yeah three months so um but it's
like it's you know some some people like
that I'm like after lazy how is she
doing she's good yeah she's got a book
coming out she wrote a book like like a
brain tumor and then she wrote a book
about it so it's coming out in October
but so that's you know I wrote I wrote
two books with her so like when she was
writing this and I was like hey do you
want me to interesting mostly fixed your
grammar and
messing this up so that's scary when
that happens I'm sure it's Harley oh
it's terrifying it's terrifying
now how many how many books have you
done I've done two and what like why not
three
I'm lazy that's literally and I put my
energy into specials after my left I did
a couple especially after the literally
lazy but it's also like the the time
like II the book world are so different
than like good news we sold three
thousand books and you're like is that
good good yes if this was 15th century
London it's so weird the book world yeah
I'm like what counts is that because you
all that matters is the New York Times
bestseller that's all you think of
that's all they think of yeah do signs
independent bookstores but now online
silent sales count and pre-sales I think
it towards the list but they didn't at
one point now they do yeah and Amazon is
huge where I am my buddy Bezos yeah was
he B's has when the companies pay the
base so um the killer bathes the killer
base so wait did he want to meet you
because of this or is it so no I had met
him before doing something else I did
this I did Bill Gates's birthday parties
oh my god I could ask me for that turn
it down at that birthday party so it was
like I was like people in the party and
confidentiality agreement I'm sure there
were a lot of famous people there too
but one table was Warren Buffett ah and
his wife Bezos and his wife and Bill
Gates and his wife and then like
Elisabeth Shue and her husband do this
gig are they eating dinner like well
it's in a restaurant guessing no it was
in their house but like that's a huge
massive house I don't like a ballroom
now these are these are the thoughts
that go through my head I don't know if
I would ever go through your head but
immediately I was thinking if I were in
that room especially if I were about to
go like perform in front of them I would
think to myself if I could get my hands
on a grenade and just throw it and blow
up that table I would change the course
of world history for us sounds like
you've got a lot of yeah I don't want to
do it no but like that table yes the
ability to change everything
so did you it was alright it was like
you know those are not as you know
there's certain no-win situation yes and
um
Bill Gates like were you like alright
this is interesting but it was it was
weird cuz I announced that I was
Midwestern and Warren Buffett's wife was
like we're from the Midwest and I'm like
lady I know that you're from Omaha do
you mean like you don't have to explain
it but how do you deal with if the
billionaires wife god forbid starts
heckling a little bit do you have to
yeah we're just going to heckler know
entirely I think you don't you know like
birthday parties are not that I've done
that many of them you don't want to ruin
someone's 60th birthday yeah it's not
your show it's their show it's their
show right and there's also just you
know none of those people were like I'll
go to Bill Gates's birthday party of jib
Cathy performing was bill a fan or did
they just say we're gonna get you a
comedian I think I think he and his kids
yeah I see so um yeah I don't know I
mean that's a weird one how much did you
have to do how much time I think it was
like 30 minutes and yet anybody but all
I want to know is that was there anybody
on before you was it was before you I
was introduced by Melinda Gates I also I
preferred the weirdest show I don't know
if I've told you this but I opened I
didn't open I performed at the NFL
owners party before a Super Bowl that
was surreal that was just really weird
because it was back when I was in
Indianapolis and so you see like all
these NFL owners and you're kind of like
a mess that Jerry - yeah yeah and so
you're doing your show and Jerry Jones
is not laughing
well the thing is is billionaires have
kind of lost touch with kind of like the
task of going to a grocery store right
so there's like some of the
commonalities just disappear getting
their life
you're relatable brand of humor all of a
sudden that's a different world peasant
was a bad show it was pretty it was
pretty awkward yeah pretty awkward I
remember George Jones not laughing and I
also remember the the the MA the
grandmother who used to own the Giants
Mehra because she was kind of a stately
old lady kind of like Barbara Bush and I
remember seeing this you know she was
probably in her 80s at the time I'm like
I can't believe I'm destroying this
woman's night kind of all civil but
they're also it's a very strange you
know put the billionaire stuff aside
it's a very strange group so like I
think there's a certain ego that you
need to undertake to even be an owner of
a sports team right so like they were
kind of like a different group at what
point did you start to realize or I
guess did you start to get booked for
like these events of the super rich and
powerful and realize that oh some of
these like really famous really
important people actually like what I do
oh it's an it's absurd it's absurd like
I you know when I met Jeff Bezos he was
like I like your stand-up and it's uh I
don't know it's weird it's weird cuz
like it's this I mean you encounter this
you're like oh yeah that's right just
because you're a professional tennis
player that doesn't mean you don't watch
standup there's mean you don't go online
and look at things I'm always floored
though but I mean I never can't act like
your floor but it's like it's really
does it ever occur to you Jeff Bezos
isn't gonna like this joke like not not
that you would offend him but just like
oh no this is like this this premises -
yeah like what's that's in your hand
well I tell you when I was at that thing
I was like when I was at the Bill Gates
thing I was like
I am beyond a doubt the dumbest person
the cater waiters were probably like PhD
students yeah it's just like I was like
gosh I just you know and the dumbest guy
here did you focus on the party at all
did you did you roast him in all order I
didn't want to roast them I just kind of
did my thing and but it was you know how
like four stand up so you know this Jim
it's like there's certain things you
figure out certain rooms you figure out
situations and so it's it's like you
know maybe if I did like all billionaire
birthday parties I'd figure out how to
do it right but it felt like one of
those things where it's kind of like the
first international show you do I change
all the reference yeah Z or Zed I don't
know and then eventually you just get so
comfortable but I don't know yet so is
one of those awkward situations but
they're kind of fun I mean like it's a
great story and you know the good or bad
is gonna be interesting for the rest of
your life to think about it and talk
about it and on some low to interact
with those people just to get just to
get a taste of what they're like in any
way shape or form has got to be
fascinating yeah oh it is I did a
birthday party and I said now it sounds
like I only do birthday / wedding
anniversary it was one of the wealthiest
families in Florida and there were the
most normal people in the world like
they had everyone from their company
there it was very it was not like they
were showing off but like I got the gig
and I'm googling I'm like alright
billionaire billionaire billionaire and
then you get there and they're like hey
how you doing you know like they were
the most normal like this family from
Philly I was like wow just regular
people yeah totally I don't like private
stuff though like corporates I mean my
act is like yeah because I just don't do
well like oh they just if I did well I
would love them because the money on
them is great and they're usually fast
gigs 30 minutes yeah I don't succeed
there and you know I always know when I
go up this is going to be ugly
they definitely there's like stuff that
topic wise like that they just freak out
and those things cuz all it takes is one
person to be like I was offended by that
joke right and they're in trouble
is there anything you want to talk about
cuz you're you're a pretty clean comic
is there anything you ever want to talk
about me like that I don't know that
might be a more of a headache than I
need I you know I think like most comics
I'm always kind of testing what I can
talk about I do feel like I'm fascinated
by politics but I also think it's like a
dead end
yep but that's not to say that I want to
talk about it because I feel like
there's such an overall fatigue but yeah
there's some topical stuff where I'm
like you know it's just not worth it
right it's not worth like it's it's
funny for us to talk about it here but
like as a stand-up you're like I
constructed the perfect Jeffrey Epstein
joke it's like I did you know it was
defense two months it's just gonna seem
archaic it's gonna be a Reagan neck
impression letting them dry was really
hard letting something go that's where
that all these guys you push on
Instagram or smart cuz you can burn it
and put it on Instagram or put it on
Twitter that stuff yeah but it's it's
heartbreaking let a good one go and
there's nothing worse than a comet
trying to make a Clinton cigar joke
you're like trying to make it feel like
it's still relevant is they just love
that joke so much they won't it's a
great joke they're like you know it was
interesting I was watching The History
Channel and they were talking with
[Laughter]
you've been doing this for 20 years you
know if you come like if a premise kind
of pops into your head or you just start
to develop the seeds of a joke that's
topical do you kind of go no cuz that'll
burn really quickly and just push it out
I just think that you know we're all
throw it on Twitter but like I don't you
know I throw less and less on Twitter
like I did a tweet last night and I'm
like I'm gonna gun that's right I just
normally just post videos on it yeah
yeah but it used to be like something
I'm like I need to think of a tweet
right I need to finger stuff is that
good for a tweet yeah it doesn't matter
it's like just I
check out what are we mad at today right
you'll find yourself checking likes and
going I hate myself or like you how many
people like this it becomes obsessive
and it's bad how many hugs do I need
right it's not even for its how much
just shut up yeah it's bad it is it's a
and it also it's like fleeting like I
you know because it's all these social
platforms are gonna be obsolete in 10
years like there's gonna be something
where we're like just tapping the air
right Jeremy that's gonna be something
weird but you go for a tweet and you're
like in your head you're going this is
the one this trust me what I tell you
this is the one that's gonna get the
likes and the retweets above and you
start to refresh then you know within 30
seconds it's just not going that fast
enough for an hour and it's got six not
taking off Oh were you when Forbes put
you on the list of the top earning
comedians is that one of those things
where you're like I don't really want it
my finance is out there or are you going
like [ __ ] yeah I accomplished this no I
mean I think it's you know to be
perfectly honest it's like in the
entertainment industry I feel like
there's nothing sexy about me
so like I'm like there's an article on
me where they're not saying clean they
probably did say you know but ya know
but I also know that everyone knows it's
all kind of like they're guessing right
not like because they would do an
article on Trump's tax returns if they
could actually get the information so
you know it's a guess but I guess the
only benefit is that some producer in
Hollywood might be like oh I guess he's
Weil rhyming that's the value of it
otherwise it's just you know then we
just get like people going hey I saw
that can you help me cure leukemia right
so you have like it's not true
they had a ballpark it and you're like
yeah but still leukemia is great but if
you haven't noticed I have five kids and
I'm probably gonna die in a year so you
have five kids and like do you like the
day-to-day stuff like I just I never was
family-oriented I see guys like you like
you seem like you love doing it
you mean like yeah there it's something
it's it's kind of art hard to articulate
it why it's so kind of refreshing and
fun it is kind of a recalibration of
priorities where you don't get caught up
and like how that tweet didn't get any
likes but there is it's absurd it's I
also you know I love stand-up you know
it's like you know the family thing it
keeps me normal but I also don't feel
like you know if I it's one thing if I
was if I it would didn't have a job that
I loved I don't know I think I'd be like
I can't believe I'm just going cuz I'm
starting and I'm just gonna go to school
events every single night so you're
president for less that let you go do
you miss any of those things like the
recital stuff yeah yeah and you feel
horrible and there's a lot of birthday
parties that happened on weekends and
you know there are like parents that
like when I show up at things are like
oh you're here oh you're normally not
here do they they say something because
there's you know there's people that you
know are at every city like being a
parent of one child is a full-time job
well yeah it is one of those things
where you're their school world getting
together yet see muffins after drop-off
and you're like I don't like people I
don't know if I've made that clear yeah
my wife like this week I had a friend
over the house who just had a baby
yeah and so she was like yeah we're
gonna get the kids together by law and
it's like okay but it's sort of be my
wife and her in the kid it's like good
I'm clear don't need like right before
she goes oh she said she's gonna bring
her husband oh and I went why what well
that's who he asked you radio
why nothing better have you heard of
this guy louis c.k hey DUI will you take
them downstairs and show them the studio
you built and I'm like I built it for me
it's not it so what uh what do you do
for fun is this where you do most of
your stuff you play golf
I don't you like and I've gotten really
bad and antisocial because the more you
do the more you can get away with it
where you know Jess will be up there for
hours with company yeah and I'll just be
down in the basement just waiting just
waiting for it to end I mean one of the
I mean I I wife her dad was very much
kind of like the disapear type yo yeah
like he I'd be like hey I'd be visiting
and he'd be like in the basement working
on the computer online I like this
arrangement it's great I think that's
the hardest thing of parenting is like
think about like the trajectory of your
life like so you had friends in grade
school you had friends in high school
you had friends in your 20s and and
along the way you kind of like as you
change you're like you know no this is
who I am
these are my friends you know I mean I
like that person that I grew up next to
but this is who I am
these are my friends I I'm choosing who
I hang out with and then you have
children and you're forced to hang
around with people that you might not
your like so you've got a
seven-month-old - yeah so we should hang
out maybe vacation together even though
we have nothing in common it's a very
strange kind of your kids made a choice
that you now have to kind of live on or
they just you you know like so then
you're struggling for things in common
they're all very nice people but it's
great but there's nothing the old like
I'm trying to figure out what's more
miserable is trying to talk about your
work with somebody who's completely not
there or listen to them talk about their
work both of its misery I'd rather
listen because there's a comic I hate
the questions and being plain cuz I
realize how boring it sounds when I
explain I don't know I just go on the
road and I just taste nothing
what what kind of comedy is
I I saw some of your standup and then
there's just a pause yeah yeah what the
hell man I don't want your feedback
unless it's great yeah it was great fine
if not just shut up I got it I'm gonna
have to pretend to be a fan we can talk
about other things like Oh Sirius XM
what channel and I'm like 103 what is
the worst you have a radio show what's
it called when a name is on what do you
guys talk about like just whatever what
are they I listened to the Springsteen
Channel
okay that's great like what do you want
me to do with that I'd rather listen to
Jeff on his own out do you know this guy
Howard Stern I always say no have you
ever heard of Howard Stern hearing a
famous comics or anything Kevin Hart no
yeah you do it in the same studio as
Howard yeah we have to whisper ours
because we're in the same room yeah he
leaves early and we take over so that's
interesting
I always feel guilty though because I am
that guy like when I do shows like this
I'm always like how do you get up so
early
which I'm sure is a conversation that
after a while you're like can we talk
about something else we're doing the
show like I feel different I don't mind
talking on the air yeah yeah because
this is what we do it's like off the air
and also somebody like you I would if
you ask me those questions I would be
able to ask you questions there would be
something there yeah but when it's stuff
you don't care about you're like there's
no reciprocal thing going on plus the
stuff I do is so foreign yeah like you
know what I mean and you don't care
about the people like I did an interview
yesterday she was very nice but asked
you like what kind of well was she just
about like what do you talk about and I
give the same answer at I'm just a
topical stuff by lot like I don't know
what to say to that question whatever it
was a bad question but I never know how
to answer it I never know how to answer
it and also it's for me it sounds
horrible I'm like I talk about horses
[Laughter]
you're talking about horses for like ten
minutes
yeah it's about horses
and then I talk about marathons for five
minutes
it sounds like torture yeah yeah in the
TED talk or comedy who is like what is
the worst thing that a guest could do
when they're on this show not give
information not talk yes that's the
worst they do like yes and no answers or
they or anything you're asking me like
um yeah or if her guest has had
something crazy happens like I don't get
into that like you know within or at
least I do I think you don't within two
questions whether it's gonna be I'm
gonna enjoy this or okay this one's
going on my back like I'm after this
guest it's not gonna do any of the heavy
lifting I think that's the worst thing
for me at least it's a confrontational I
know people like hearing it if they're
funny if they were talking about
different stuff the only thing they can
do that I hate is just not give anything
it's like if you have an astronaut in
the studio who is in space for a year
and has no interesting stories and every
question you ask they look at you like
you're an idiot in the time you've been
in you've given us more interesting
space stories that man who a year what
does this [ __ ] want and they were
actually like I wanted to bust Jim's
balls on the questions but I was like
I'd like to hear the answer to that
question too I remember when I used to I
was on for like this year or so I was on
Conan once a month and so I would do
this segment and then I would watch the
show cuz like when I was a kid I would
watch late-night shows religiously and I
was like I'd love to do that and then
for like this two-year period I would
watch Conan and there would be like good
guess and then there would be bad guess
and then every now and then there would
be like oh my gosh this is a really hard
job
yeah really hard job where the Conan is
carrying them like there's like shows
like where someone thinks they're funny
but they're not funny but he can't bury
them right do you mean at least in this
environment you guys couldn't look at
each other and but he was out there solo
and I was like wow I like the guys that
aren't funny
that will
and try to out funny coalminer whoever
the host is and you're like what do you
just let him let him carry you here like
the worst is a story like if I tell a
story that goes nowhere which will
happen frequently I know it and I can
say it the worst is when a story is
going nowhere and then nobody can
acknowledge this stinks that's not as a
terrible boring story the person telling
it doesn't know it's boring the host
can't just go what the [ __ ] was that you
just everyone has to pretend it was a
great story when it wasn't it's like
that that's a really difficult no it's
pretty bad when people come in with like
a lot of energy hey what's going on guys
and then they sit down and some how much
is shuts off yeah like what happened to
the guy or it's all energy and there's
nothing interesting coming out right
there just shout what and they're nice
and you can't even get mad at them
because they're fun to be around like so
when someone's focusing on like do they
bring everything back to a thing they're
plugging do you ever get that
oh yeah it's interesting you bring that
up on my Amazon yeah as I said in the
book or this is the worst when someone
writes a book and then you go ask a
question not not not the whodunit miss
you buddy yeah really well it's in the
book you're gonna have to read it I'm
like look nobody is gonna 25 minutes we
have to talk or there's a half hour you
can't just tell me it read the book tell
me the story
people will still read the book Jim and
I oh we always know those like we'll
never actually have the conversation but
right after the segment like we'll go to
the bathroom or something be standing in
the urinal and I just wanted us to just
go oh just start giggling
one more Jim and Sam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
Sirius XM app